the finale of House of the Dragon
masterfully echoed the show's earliest
episodes while also improving one of the
most impressive sets in Game of Thrones
history throughout season 1 the painted
table of Dragonstone has made brief but
uneventful appearances this is the very
same table around which Stannis
Baratheon and later Daenerys Targaryen
draw up their battle plans in Game of
Thrones conquering westerness would be
easy for you
but you're not here to be Queen of the
ashes rhaenyra expresses a similar wish
in the finale while standing around the
same table
I do not wish to rule over a kingdom of
Ash and Bone
we know from the books that the table
which doubles as a map of Westeros was
commissioned by none other than King
aegon the first himself before his
Conquest which is why it's in
Dragonstone instead of King's Landing
many fans considered it one of the
coolest pieces of set design in the
screen adaptations of Martin's world and
that's before we knew it could be
illuminated apparently the instruction
manual got lost sometime in between the
dance of the dragons and Robert's
Rebellion as no one in Game of Thrones
seemed to know about the table's awesome
light up feature if you experienced Deja
Vu when Otto arrived with his Envoy at
Dragonstone that was intentional the
hand of King aegon II arrives
unannounced to offer a nearer terms
Damon is there waiting with guards who
are loyal to the blacks But Otto says
he's under strict instructions to only
deliver Queen Allison's message to
Princess rhaenyra The Black Queen flies
in on the back of Cyrax and lands on the
bridge behind the green party she
Dismounts then positions herself in
between Damon and Otto the two men are
hoping for war Damon outwardly so on is
clearly hoping for an escalation on the
Rogue Prince's part so he has
justification to kill them all and
stymie any challenge to his grandson
it's left to Rainier again to force
cooler heads to Prevail she's angry
enough that her Birthright has been
stolen to toss Otto's pin into the water
below but after he shows her Allison's
message she's steady enough to tell him
she'll give her an answer the following
day
King's Landing will have my answer on
the moon
the scene is a callback to House of the
Dragon episode 2 in which Auto Sales to
Dragonstone to confront Damon about his
seizure of what's supposed to be The
Heirs seat back then a teenage Rainier
landed Cyrax in almost exactly the same
spot and walked to almost exactly the
same place between who was then just her
uncle and her father's vulture of a hand
but during that debacle her back was
turned to Otto while she dealt with
Damon in episode 10 her back is to her
husband as she tries to outwit the
engineer of the coup against her Alison
Hightower doesn't show up in episode 10
but it's clear she thinks she has an ace
up her sleeve before rhaenyra gives Otto
her non-answer he hands her a folded up
piece of paper and lets her know that
the queen has not forgotten the love
they once had for each other as her
Envoy Auto insists that Ellison wants to
avoid Bloodshed and broker peas rhaenyra
opens up what viewers might have
expected to be a handwritten message
instead we see an illustrated page from
a history textbook this is the page that
a very young rhaenyra tore out of the
book when she was supposed to to be
studying with Allison at the SEPTA's
behest Allison's token of affection is
also shrewd statecraft that she kept the
page is meant to show her friend turned
enemy that she has been pining for what
they once had all these years but she's
also hoping the ploy works in the
Green's favor it's significant that the
entry is about nymeria a woman who ruled
alongside her husband and who brought
her people together it's also symbolic
that in their youth a willful rhaenyra
ripped out the page and gave it to an
obedient Allison while as mothers a
boulder Allison Returns the page to a
rhaenyra who's worried about Duty and
honor in discussing their path forward
Queen rhaenyra tells the black Council
that she wants to know who her allies
are before she sends people to war in
her name her loyalists assure her some
houses like celtagar can be dependent
upon for support but the fealty of
houses who swore Oaths long ago will
have to be reaffirmed Chief among these
are houses Tully Aaron Stark and
Baratheon we know how that last one
panned out but the black's efforts to
secure alliances with the other three
will likely be the order of business in
season two that means we'll probably be
meeting the ancestors of the tolles
Starks and Aarons and visiting these
iconic Game of Thrones locations
technically it'll be the show's second
visit to the veil as we did get a brief
stop over there when Damon knocked off
Ria Royce we can't say if the dragon
fight happens in the show as it does in
Fire and Blood it's a stormy night in
both versions which makes it hard for
onlookers to see in written accounts
what everyone agrees upon is that aemond
didn't fly to Storm's end with the
intent to kill Luke and that all anyone
saw was two dragons tangling in a fury
of fire and lightning House of the
Dragon renders eamon's kin slang of Luke
as something closer to manslaughter than
murder when they jump on the backs of
their dragons Luke and aymond both speak
to their mounts in High Valyrian though
the one-eyed princess evil laughter and
his insistence that Luke owes him a debt
suggests otherwise once Eric sprays
vegar in the face with flames aemond
tries to put on the brakes he screams
dohyrus at vegar who Chomps down on poor
Luke and Eric's anyway the word dohiris
might sound familiar to Game of Thrones
fans
foreign
is a common phrase used in essos which
translates to all men must serve often
said in conjunction with Valar morghulis
which means all men must die it's also
the title of the first episode of season
three of Game of Thrones for the
purposes of House of the dragon that two
Royal boys can't get their dragons to
dohiris indicates viserys was right
there are power men should never have
trifled with
[Music]